Hello, Pennsylvania, Conan O'Brien here
reminding you to register to vote.
Listen, PA. Can I call you PA?
No? Oh, sorry.
Pennsylvania, you're one of
the original 13 colonies.
You started this democracy
and now it's in trouble.
We need you.
We can't leave voting to
places like the West Coast.
We've got earthquakes and
Kardashians to deal with.
We need the OG 13 to step
up and vote like hell.
Every election year the pundits
go on and on about Florida.
They gotta win Florida.
Well, I'm sick of hearing about Florida.
F Florida.
What about Pennsylvania?
I say you can't win the White House
if you don't win Pennsylvania.
So please register to
vote by October 19th.
So you can decide who wins the White House
and piss off Florida.
Still not convinced?
Listen to this joke.
The Monongahela River in
Western Pennsylvania flows north
and the first time you see it
you think, wow, that is Erie.
Register to vote, or I'll come
to Erie and tell that joke
and only that joke in person
at the D'Angelo Performance Arts Center.
You have until October 19th to
register to vote and stop me.
You can do it online@whenweallvote.org.